so just out of curiosity have you ever
taken any honors classes any higher
learning maybe you were in high school
elementary ap magnet did you ever take
anything like that because the mayor of
new york city thinks all of those people
that take classes like that is not fair
and he wants to get rid of it and i'm
going to read a new york times story
that just came out about him wanting to
do this with his last three months left
in new york as the mayor and i'm going
to react to it and i want to get your
thoughts as well
here's a new york times story de blasio
to phase out
new york city gifted and talent program
mayor de blasio on friday unveiled a
plan to overhaul gifted and talented
education in new york city elementary
school calling for sweeping changes to
highly select a program that has been
widely criticized for exasperating
exasperating segregation in the nation's
largest school system under mr de
blasio's plan released when he has just
three months left in office elementary
schools who are currently enrolling
gifted classes would become the final
cohort in the existing program which
means the tests given to kindergarten
students to screen for the gifted
programs already suspended in part
because the city's advisory school board
refused to renew it last year would
become permanently done would be
permanently ended right and here's what
he says here's what his thoughts are and
a couple other thoughts from parents
from both sides here's his thoughts i
bet you a lot of parents are going to
look at this plan and say this is the
reason we're going to stay says de
blasio
in an interview on the radio adding that
for far more children would have the
opportunity to receive more accelerated
learning than under the existing system
but some families and elected officials
who support keeping aspects of the
current gifted system sharply disagree
with them now this obviously is
happening when he wants to run for
governor next year because that's his
plan so the last three months he's just
getting the last stuff done before next
you're running for governor so let me
continue with some of the other stuff in
this article it's gifted and talented
programs that have contributed to
racially segregated classrooms and
schools for thousands of students
citywide interesting let me read this
one more time it's the gifted and
talented program
has contributed to racially segregated
classrooms and schools for thousands of
students
citywide right though about 70 percent
of the roughly 1 million public school
students in new york are black and
latino so again out of the 1 million
students
700 000 are black and latino about 75 of
the roughly 16 000 in the gifted
elementary school classes are white or
asian american okay so out of the 1
million only 1.6 percent
are in the gifted class 75 of that 1.6
are white or asian-american fine
the question i pose is the final one why
why why is it that
maybe 70
of the 1 million that are
african-american latino and then the
people that are in it are white and
asian american is it because
maybe they value education a little bit
more maybe is it because they're
spending money into tutoring maybe is it
because parents are spending time doing
homework with their kids maybe is it
because standards are a little bit
higher maybe i can tell you from
personal experience as a guy that went
to school in the u.s public school i've
never been to private school i went to
public school from seventh grade to
senior in glendale california i went to
wilson junior high school seven through
nine and i went to glendale high school
ten to ten through twelve the following
year they changed nine through twelve
but when i went there was ten through
twelve i've never taken an ap class i've
never taken an honors class i've never
taken a magnet class and i never
deserved to get into any of those
classes because i never put the effort
because when i came home nobody expected
me to get high grades there was no level
of expectation on me to get any kind of
big grades so i didn't pay attention to
it nobody sat and did homework with me
after school it wasn't like a thing not
saying anything to my parents that
wasn't something that they gauged grades
on and success it never happened my
parents were divorced and i never went
through it but there were other kids
that were part of gifted programs so
should they lower that to make me feel
better about myself because maybe my
feelings are hurting because i'm not as
good as them
isn't competition a little bit good for
the kids i don't know let me continue
with the article here and again i want
to hear your thoughts on this as well so
robin keller an elected parent leader in
district 2 said friday that mr de
blasio's announcement felt like a
political stunt
and that the mayor would be leaving a
pile of bloody broken bone fragments for
mr adams to clean up who is about to
become the next potential mayor of new
york city but carla
has a completely different position here
here's what she said carlos stanius a
parent in the bedford
stuyvesant section of brooklyn said she
believed that the gifted programs made
it more difficult for children and
regular classes to thrive why
she says if we're just dumping a bunch
of resources into the gifted and
talented everybody else suffers because
they didn't know somebody or they
couldn't afford a tutor right so this
her argument is why are we making the
gifted and putting additional programs
for them to do better we should use
those those resources
in a different way so here's kind of
what this looks like what they're saying
is the ones that are thriving the ones
that are not let's dumb these down to
make this equal this is what we should
do you know this kind of what we should
do it's kind of like saying hey lebron
james he may be the best basketball
player in the nba and then there's a
12th man the 12th man on the team never
gets a minute to play but lebron gets 40
minutes i think we should lower lebron's
minutes and increase this guy's minutes
so it's not fair because they should
play the same amount of minutes would
you watch the nba if the 12 man that
maybe is not as good in basketball gets
the same amount of minutes how about
modeling how about we get the best
models you know the best looking models
and
let's make it equal no matter what we do
there are things that you and i are not
good at
and if in a gifted program you don't
have a standard for kids to be thriving
what ends up taking place i think to me
this is obviously political stunt that
they were talking about i think it's
bigger than that
think about if your parents
get a divorce okay and your father was a
father whose standards were high when
your mom and dad were together he
expected you to clean your bed you
didn't like it but he expected you he
expected you to clean he expected to do
wash the car maybe he expected you to
read your book do homeworks and then he
had fun with him but that had high
standards and expectation your mom and
dad get a divorce your mom leaves your
dad and goes and marries a new guy named
joey
joey could care less if you do your
homework joey could care less if you
read books he doesn't read book he just
watches football at night and has beer
so what happens to you
the standards and expectation keeps
dropping drop and drop and drop and drop
and then what happens then all of a
sudden like you can get away with
anything right but at least in this
situation the standard and expectation
was somebody believed you were capable
of doing more sometimes people and kids
need an environment just to have someone
that thinks you're capable of more i
think you can do more i think you can do
better i think you can strive to get
into a magnet i think you can get into
ap i think you can get into honors when
that standard and expectation is not
there it is what it is so do we not put
the onus on the parents should we take
the pressure off the parents should we
take the pressure off single family
households that the responsibility needs
to be on them is it the other kid's
fault that the parents are maybe doing
the right thing so the other kid that
the parents are doing the right thing
should be punished for this this doesn't
make any sense to me at all
to do something like this and i tell you
if i lived in new york city and my kids
were in that new york city public
program we would leave in a heartbeat
because i would not want to be in a
place where my kids don't have something
to chase and compete for you need high
expectation for somebody to want to
scale and perform to that kind of a
level and the situation the direction
they're going right now that's not going
to be taking place it's an unfortunate
situation by the way i'm also a full
firm believer that there's a group of
people
that no matter what you ever put in
their way they're still going to find a
way to win you can have a choo choo
train coming their way they're going to
stop the choo-choo train there's certain
people that are too stubborn that no
matter what environment you put them
they're going to find a way to get that
information
but i think there's also the percentage
that needs to be challenged needs to be
pushed needs to have something to be
going for i think that group the small
group of that 1.6 percent this group is
going to take a hit and i hope this
program doesn't last a long time and
somebody comes back and turns it over
and goes back to having a highly gifted
program because america is ran the
greatest innovation i'm looking at this
camera here this light here this other
camera here this is being done by people
that are better at this stuff than i am
america is ran by those who are willing
to pay the price slightly more than
others and america the greatest
organizations in america are ran by
leaders who have high standards and
expectations of their people the moment
those two drop everybody takes a hit
america's historically been the leader
of the world because we've had higher
standards than others and now others are
following our standards we get rid of
that
we're going to be in major trouble
anyways you may or may not agree with me
if you agree with me give me a thumbs up
if you don't give me a thumbs down if
you fully agree with this subscribe to
the channel but i got another video i
want you to watch matter of fact i want
it to be two videos i want you to watch
one of them is 15 things that school
will not teach you if you've never seen
this one you may want to watch this one
and the other one is every university's
worst nightmare yes they're not going to
be happy about these types of events
taking place choose one of them you want
to watch either way have a great week
take care bye
[Music]